Life is
lonely
like Ramadan Kareem
[Music]
There is a blessing in Suhoor [
Music]
We go out and enchant people in the atmosphere of the siege
and poverty that we are living in and the
depressing atmosphere, so we go out to lighten their burdens a little and make them happy
and make them feel the atmosphere of Ramadan with chants,
religious supplications
and its charms, and relieve them a little of the atmosphere that
we are living in.
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] I swear it
felt like Ramadan, a year different from all the years.
People prepared early and
prepared with lights, equipment, and illumination, and they prepared for
the month of Ramadan, and from early on,
people were traveling and gathering, and in the
streets there were many, many beautiful gatherings in the neighborhoods
[Music]